une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre présenté par kiss me le
podcast on parle de ce qu'ont vécu nos
invités dati ci-dessus ph quentin avec
moi doom plan des caisses me viennent de
lancer une nouvelle que next collection
de huit design la collection s'appelle
nature s'est inspiré des images et de la
texture de la nature vous le savez kiss
me plante un arbre à chaque caisse
vendus et bien là pour deux douzaines le
silver le skyline à chaque étui vendu ça
va être dix arbres qui seront plantés
c'est pas rien donc allez sur leur site
web et une autre de promo le sf qu'à
nice pour procurer cette nouvelle
collection love honnêtement les caisses
sont débiles d'hommes s'est tenu cette
semaine au pas de kafka plaisait grand
honneur de recevoir le chroniqueur
patrick lagacé qui s'est hélas eu la
super star venue au québec qui le dit
lui-même mauvais exposé bush répliqué
aux expos choquée juste exposé comme il
comme il se doit comme
exposé parce que sergei de grâce à
l'appui c'est l'fun d'avoir chronic'art
espace public qu'est la nuance pour n'en
parle beaucoup de nuances dans le
podcast
sa valeur son importance puis justement
le fait qu'on le perd de plus en plus on
a parlé de 2,12 lui provient son son
amour de la chronique ce désir de france
mais c'est le sa rigueur au travail on a
parlé de plusieurs sujets d'actualité
c'était vraiment super arrêtez de parler
de conspirationnisme sujet qui nous
intéresse on ne parlait de de trop de
choses pour faire la liste ici alors
écoutez pas de cas si vous ne serez pas
déçus on va les remercier nos
commanditaires sans qui rien ne serait
possible
[Musique]
le podcast est présenté par walter gala
amateur de pitou amateurs de quoi cela
n'est ni tout chien
mode de poils qui jappe
liste les vrais son dégraissage
l'ivresse à wadia meilleures compagnies
d'ici on les connaît bien même avec les
proprios et les six maillots marty vient
même pas son podcast ici on les adore et
une angoisse souvent ils font les
meilleurs produits pour chiens plus cinq
hauts responsables
c'est si tout ce que ça prend puis à des
produits dans la spéciale pas nous avons
est moi j'ai des amis qui m'écrivent
pour me dire qu'il commande world war
hulk parce qu'ils font des produits qui
sont hypoallergéniques pour vos chiens
dont il ya des chiens des fois qu'ils
ont des bas et qui ont des allergies en
fait tu peux je préfère manger ce genre
de produits dont deux options des
gâteries à base de grillons des gâteries
vegan à base d'algues de la gaspésie et
de pulpe de fruits recyclé ils font de
la nourriture pour chiens à base
d'insectes il faut aussi la nourriture
pour chiens à base de poisson durable
donc ça c'est quoi ces de la carpe
asiatique qui détruit les fonds marins
qui doit être repêché dans quoi je
travaille conjointement avec des
pêcheurs d'amérique du nord pour
contrôler les fonds marins c'est ultra
protéiné
les produits sont aussi nutritifs que
bon bon goût pour vos chiens donc c'est
vraiment la totale on est extrêmement
content de s'associer avec encore une
fois qu'on a un cap pour moi pour vous
qu il s est vendu pour 20 % drabek sur
le site web qu'on voit maintenant la
description de ce podcast ci merci la
gainward est ouvrier ou le tout donne ou
ou
le podcast et prétendent y participent à
l'étude les connaissent et ils nous
commente est souvent il commandait en
fait prêt d'affaires comme occupation
double une émission que j'adore que
j'écoute religieusement qui c'est du bon
cette année les candidats sont en forme
c'est pourquoi son enfant parce qu'ils
dorment sur des lits en seriez politique
toi tu leur donnes tout les le régime à
dormir sur des matelas police et
les niveaux pour du péage pour nous
tendons yes un oreiller orthopédique en
fait c'est le premier à rayer du genre
fait entièrement au canada qui a une
mousse anti bactérienne est aussi une
nouvelle technologie de réguler est de
régulation de la température qui a s'est
inclinée légèrement donc ça vous aide à
lutter contre la main de sommeil les
brûlures d'estomac les maux de dos donc
je rappelle que le film burn after
reading ouais c'est tout le long du film
le personnage de georges souris se
promène comme avec une jarre de sites
d'oreiller dans le fond là en triangle
bleu finalement tu apprends qu'il
utilise comme shakespeare aux exams
langues on peut penser que pense-t-il
sachez qu'avec les oreillers
orthopédique de police lui même utilisé
comme shakespeare a donc monté un petit
plus basse en impôts évidemment vous
savez pourquoi on a cru promo pour
l'autre si vous voulez vous procurer cet
arrêt est là en fait c'est 25 % de
rabais en une seule école ou filtre 25
en un mot on va mettre le lien dans la
décision du podcast puis utiliser cet
arrêt le soin pour dormir ou
toute autre activité qui vous viendra
c'est beaucoup pour ça pour ça
allez-vous coop seuil au
persil baril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces vols patrick merci au public le
plaisir je veux dire une affaire au
début parce que ma mère allait insister
que je le dise et dompter son préféré à
trouve que tu écris vraiment bien puis a
seulement dit pas une formation en
littérature aucune aucune aucune j'ai
appris à écrire en lisant way dati
depuis
en fait moi je voulais écrire des
chroniques ce que je défends je veux pas
que des rumeurs je n'ai pas écrit des
essais depuis tout le temps
15 - écoute autour de 12 13 ans j'ai je
disais la presse ce qg journées de la
fin puis après ça au juste les sports
l'utilisait les l'actualité ou gisèle
actualité puis
10 ado je commence à lire la presse puis
un moment et j'ai cliqué jockey les gens
qui écrivent des articles sont payés
pour faire ce que j'ai commencé à me
dire ça pique les femmes évidemment les
parents voulaient pas trop tôt que je
fasse journalisme pas ce que c'était
c'était pas s'étaient vus comme popeye a
pas de débouchés lavedan le terrain et
le quand j'ai commencé à les les
chroniqueurs va la fin de mon
adolescence je me suis dit ok je veux
faire ça moi j'ai toujours aimé lire
donc qu'à ma formation mental pour
l'écriture ça toujours été la chronique
réponse à ta mémoire quoi sans nom
sylvie c'est lui répond c'est celui de
celui
j'ai pas aucune formation à la
littérature a fait quoi
et crée je pense que ça fait partie des
choses qui sans enseigne mais qui
s'apprennent pas comment est-ce que
tu l'as où tu le peux je te papa décret
de bien écrire à cordes et des
participants à ces mets et créer des
trucs pour un public
tut tut tut après comme tu apprends par
mimétisme venu j'aime c'est l'idée de
quelque chose qui est qui s'enseigne
mais qui s'apprend pas
le
l'enseignement mettons la littérature
moi c'est ma formation je les fais de là
dedans je jetais un crise en littérature
puis puis la même chose demain qu'on
parle de musique l'été quand tu apprends
ses bancs d'école là littérature la
musique n'importe quelle forme parce que
ça permet de faire c'est de cibler un
problème s'il y en a mais ça ne permet
pas nécessairement de
de créer quelque chose qui va rejoindre
les gens je pense à fait essentielle
mettons que tu écris une chanson
quelques clics c était donc qu'un
travail de la musique mettons la plaque
était un musicien propose une chanson
puis le tout tu le répètes pas
nécessairement écrite cette chanson là
mais tu vas capable de savoir qu'est ce
qui fonctionne pas dans telle modulation
nantais la fois comprendre pourquoi
met-on ça passe il n'y a pas de règle et
sauna tant pis c'est pas c'est pas
inutile non plus empreinte des musiciens
j'imagine qu'ils qui font de la musique
sont super bons sans avoir su vilcot
puis ça veut pas dire que parce que ne
pas suivi les quotes-parts fais ton bac
en musique que tu peux pas être un
chanteur ou un musicien mais mais il ya
quelque chose dans la création je pense
qu'il est un peu mystérieux aussi c'est
pas inutile même strbac n'était pas ce
grand talent là tu veux devenir
ingénieur de son d'autres
musiciens
ok
mais mais oui effectivement mais
[Musique]
intime de quelqu'un que c'est cette
énergie canadien
en team de quelqu'un qui avait un peu
plus les connaissances
nous disait que
d'enfance ici c'est le moment les
l'automne ne plus occuper tel oui
occupés et surexposé ce
pauvre exposé le cema face dans la fiche
wikipédia comment tu vis
surtout dans un moment où est-ce que
tu es quand même tu es quand même la
cible de certains groupes à 100 fier à
tofield twitter dès le collabo par
excellence oui oui mais ça
pour moi le fiel c'est pas différent en
fait c'est différent en intensité comme
tout est différent pendant la pandémie
donc ce n est que décuplée m'écoute
j'écrivais la chronique dans le journal
étudiant quand j'avais 21 ans internet
n'existait pas les gens à envoyer des
lettres d'insultés ou des lettres de
remerciements puis dès l'âge mais pour
ce qui est d'être over expose
un côté que cette année pour le show de
radio qui toujours là et la chronique
est toujours là mais la nouvelle
émission de télé
donc ça c'est une chose et il ya aussi
y aussi la série la traque qui s'en
viennent nous gardent donc ça fait
beaucoup de projets en même temps
chi chi chi ce qui est inhabituel
d'habitude toujours occupée mais leur
cette année c'est vraiment mais c'est
drôle c'est que un chroniqueur qu'on
voit ça fasse autant team puis oui
j'imagine qu'ils étaient en vacances
métier le port pour avoir ta face au
tollé billboard 30-15 par le chemin le
plus direct par la façon dont la dame de
la paix choix d'être comédien ou
chanteurs
le mot important c'est le verbe choisit
quand ce que j'avais choisi mostefa des
chroniques ce que je voulais c'est
d'être journaliste puis éventuellement
chroniqueur dans un journal puis même
que à l'époque c'est je te parle 10h30
en 40 ans la légende l'écrit méprisait
les autres formes comme la télé je ne
faisais pas sorti le vrai journalisme
ceux des journaux maintenant c'est la
radio qui méprisent et podcasts
mais moi j'ai g j'ai été un peu teinté
de ce début de la carrière comme aux
régimes politiques la télé n'est pas
pour moi sanaa les normes inexactes bien
avant la plèbe russe pour la plèbe pour
ceux qui qui qui sont bien coiffée puis
un mot et j'ai vu le pouvoir de ce but
le fun ii se sait quand tu parles du du
mépris ya aucun genre qui devraient
mépriser un aux jo il ya du bon stock se
fait partout il ya du bon stock sera pas
de casque il ya du mauvais état qu'ils
soient au podcast moi j'ai commencé à
faire des blogs quand ce n'était pas à
la mode dans les médias je t'ai pas le
premier ni en avait puis il y avait les
journalistes sérieux qui méprisait sont
nombreux ce mépris là c'est souvent une
forme de jalousie une forme de snobisme
mal placé puis c'est ce mépris dont tu
parles de la radio écoute moi je la
perçois pas le je te le dis gentiment
mais je peux comprendre que un nouveau
joueur qui arrive le même voix est
regardé de haut par plein de joueurs
dans l'écosystème puis ce qui fait sa
force dans un sens ou la manière qu'ils
tiraient leur épingle du jeu ces deux
pôles et ces autres médias leur médium
l' écoute je me suis pas posé des
questions profondes comme ça moi je me
perds actifs et que j'aime se faire
plein d'affaires je me rappelle des ti
cupide avoir peur de m'ennuyer puis
quand je m'ennuyais
c'était quand je vais rien à faire
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui me
peser aujourd'hui je m'ennuie jamais
j'ai pas le temps
on choisit tous nos prisons je travaille
beaucoup c'est une forme de prison
mais j'ai rien j'ai pas vraiment choisi
j'ai plongé là dedans pis ce que je
constate c'est que ça a fait de moi un
meilleur journaliste donne un exemple
qu'un quand j'ai commencé à crier
c'était en 2003 au journal de moyens je
faisais à peu près quatre chroniques par
semaine
j'ai commencé à faire les francs tireurs
et là aux francs tireurs
ça m'a forcé à
plonger dans des sujets dans lesquels
j'aurai pas plonger autrement parce que
tu fais partie d'une équipe et on
pourrait trouver telle personne en
prenant reportage à telle place on
préfère tel sujet je n'aurais pas pensé
à ce seul mais ça c'est sûr que ça
nourrit ma chronique de la même façon
que la chronique ont nourri des
frontières j'ai commencé à faire le blog
j'ai commencé à faire les francs tireurs
en septembre 2005 le blog c'était un
décembre 2005 l'a plutôt que de créer
quatre fois par semaine j'ai crevé
quatre fois par jour avec le musc de
l'écriture ici s'est fortifiée du combat
avec tout ça tous se nourrit chaque
partie de la pratique journalistique
nourrir une autre pratique c'est là que
ça devient et c'est là que j'ai pas fait
de choix j'ai plongé là dedans puis à
m'amener tu deviens descend dans toutes
les sphères du jeudi 3 - fou quand tu
fais de la tv de la radio lacaune est
passé au début de la foux c'est sur les
terres à des fins mais non je serais pas
contre l'idée fois d'aider des
chroniques et se faisait à l'époque où
est-ce que tu regardes des fois les
chaumières l'émission les francs-tireurs
c'est je veux pas ah ouais je veux pas
et que
je tombe parfois sur des chroniques de
mes premières années à
presse
j'aime pas ça je bois l'éthique je vois
les trucs je vois quel point ce n'est
pas fluide je vois comment je voulais
faire du style je te dise pas que je
veux plus faire ça mais maintenant ça
coule de source mais en fait la télé
quant au début le jeudi ont dit voici le
dossier de recherche de l'entrevue que
jacques parizeau c'est la semaine
prochaine j'ai pas été préparé à ça je
ne dis pas qu'ils m'ont pas encadré mais
si c'était à refaire j'aurais aimé qu'on
me dise écoute fait hum dans un plat
ventre
j'ai commencé à faire des entrevues qui
était de descente à la télé quand j'ai
commencé à faire mes plans d'entrevue
tout est question puis après ça le truc
c'est de vous le savez vous fait des
entrevues le truc c'est un plan dans ta
tête tu t'en sors s'il faut c'est comme
conduire c'est tonton itinéraire mais si
tu vois une belle route avec un beau
paysage tu peux tu autorisé à sortir
l'entrevue c'est exactement ça au début
la première saison c'était terrible je
veux jamais revu c'est drôle je tendais
dans un entrevue que te fais depuis
cette histoire là exactement puis je me
suis
jamais fait
mais on sait jamais écrits de questions
mais tenté mais probablement que si la
première entrevue que j'avais fait de ma
vie avec jacques parizeau me serais tu
écris des gosses mais mesut voix c'est
ça c'est de cet ordre là c'est comme
tarik devant quelqu'un d'assez costaud
puis après ça moi je t'aime tu as posé
des questions dans des entrevues de
journalisme écrit ou la question c'est
ça fait pas partie du produit final à
telle est la question est dans le
produit final avec un man of en tirions
scrappé une autre vue complète que j'ai
fait que j'ai faite parce que ils ont
peu plus la rescapée au montage mais
question était trop long je posais des
questions aventure à
l'écrit je peux tu interviewé des bons
ya là quand dit la chanteuse fait penser
dessus que
il y aurait telle réaction plutôt petit
tu reviens à question après 45 s'annonce
correcte atv jeudi le monde et pas
seulement les particuliers dans de cadre
est
ce que tu es au terme de la en termes de
la forme
tempo soit regarder ces choses là mais
ce qui en termes du fonds mettons des
fois tu tu repenses à des choses de
dites des choses de faites des
chroniques étaient écrites se trouve que
ton point de vue et décalé par rapport à
ce que tu es maintenant au ton opinion à
ce sport à certains sujets
est très bonne question
parce que tu fais de l'opinion veut veut
pas ou peu puis j'imagine qu'en faisant
c'est voué à changer d'opinion
les quatre change d'opinion sur un sujet
tu essaies de le dire mais sur les
convictions
je te dirais que ça n'a pas beaucoup
évolué et des fois mon regard va changer
mais tu arrives avec taghrid analyse
puis tu analyses événement que cette
grille la fête devrait pas trop changer
prend les accommodements raisonnables
est question identitaire je pensais la
même chose quand j'étais au journal de
moyens donc j'arrive à la presse j'ai
les mêmes points de vue et pour moi qui
ai qu'une enseignante porte le voile
personnellement je sais que je m'inscris
dans tes en marge du consensus québécois
moi ça me dérange pas ça me dérangeait
pas vains
si situe si tu écris toujours au gré de
l'opinion publique si tu veux aller
toujours et du bombarde pignon public
va forcément être contredits puis on va
ressortir des vieilles chronique pour
votre écoute pour ce que tu disais il ya
cinqans ait 15 ans je te dis pas que
c'est jamais arrivé mais ça arrive pas
du lean ouais
j'ai jolie je l'étais chronique assez
régulièrement puis justement sur sur
cette question là je pense que c'était
suite au débat a subi ciltyri un jeu
chronique sur la question posée à
françois blanchette puis
ce que j'aimais principalement par
rapport à cette question lost et que tu
te positionner pas d'un
dans
ces biens ou c'est mal où le québec est
raciste ou non tu faisais juste remettre
en place las la situation qui est ce que
cette espèce de deux degrés de nuances
lot suis vite ta carrière parce qu'en ce
moment on remarque facilement dans
toutes les dans tous les médias qu'il y
aura une polarisation claire des
opinions mais j'ai pas l'impression que
t'es jamais vraiment tombé là-dedans ce
que je me trompe ça tu étais un effort
conscient et coûte peut-être des buts
qu'on prend au début quand tu te
connectes fait remarquer
oui tout le moins d'expérience fait qd
et peut-être plus dans le manque de
nuance moi j'essaie
des fois il ya des situations tout cas
mende qui était pas de nuances mais
souvent les situations sont nuancés
oui j'essaie de faire la part des choses
mais des fois ça fait peut-être des
moins bonnes chroniques ou des
chroniques qui ont un moins grand
rayonnement franchement 600 ch - mais
j'essaie toujours de m'inscrire parce
que les anglais appellent la longue et
dans la durée c'est à dire que ça se
peut que je fasse un incendie de forêt
une journée avec une bonne chronique pas
nuance un bon des fois il ya des
situations où il y en a pas de nuages
mais dans la durée le lien que j'ai avec
les lecteurs fait que je pense qu'ils
vont vouloir lire des trucs qui sont
plus nuancés puis c'est plus payant long
terme c'est le pari que je fais ta qu'a
l'air déclic d'allah il dit grant s'est
depuis dit justement des opinions
tranchées puncher c'est encore ça marche
encore ton conforme à ses scores
possible de le faire avec nuance et que
je sais c'est vrai qu'on le voit moins
en moins je pense que c'est possible dit
à la presse je n'ai pas payé au clic ya
peu d'incitatifs à une unique comprend
ils font ils font le pari que il ya des
choses importantes des fois dont il faut
parler ça gênait rome - clic mais on va
le faire quand même il fait qu'il ya pas
d'incitatif moi j'ai entendu des
histoires de groupes de presse où il y
avait des incitatifs parfois financiers
qui sont liés
au clic clac c'est sûr que
si ça c'est le cas tu vas tomber là bas
tu vas parler des trucs qui sont
polarisant qui vont qui vont qui vont
générer du partage du clic de
l'indignation les gens sont pas d'accord
et monte lire chez nous on n'a pas ça
mais je trouve que c'est une excellente
affaire je convaincu moi je regarde pas
mes statistiques où il les connaît
projet de jeu c'est pas comme un tas de
lecteurs essai transformé et de lecteurs
est-ce que je suis dans les crânes cas
les plus lus de la presse je pense que
vous probablement je veux pas savoir
combien je veux pas savoir ce qu'ils
pensent parce que je veux pas tomber
dans le piège de toujours refaire ce
jeu c'est que des médias anglo saxons là
aucun d'anglais puis aux états unis
gérer une conférence il ya quelques
années à toronto pire des médias ils ont
dans salle de rédaction tu as un écart
s'est dit quel texte est le plus lu en
temps réel combien de gens sont en train
de l'ailé en temps réel - moi j'écoutais
ça mais je m'étouffe s'est rendu de plus
du sport que oui parce que pour moi il
ya comme une alchimie dans le
journalisme qui est très mystérieuse il
faut pas toujours donné aux gens ce
qu'ils pensent vouloir vaut que tu leur
fasse découvrir des trucs
pipi si tu y vas jusqu'au clé ben tu
vois les leur donner ce qu'ils ont aimé
hier moi ce qu'ils aimeraient demain
mais qui savent pas encore qu'ils vont
aimer c'est ça le métier de journaliste
ou s'il essaie de mettre loupé ce
autant que faire se peut mais oui ça
fédère four de l'équation mais si tu
n'es pays coquelicot c'est un gros
incitatifs est pays a généré du clic
moi je trouve ça dangereux parce que tu
vas aller au sujet facile tout le temps
des fois le sujet facile y est là et on
est tous on est tous susceptibles de
tomber dedans mais si tu commences à
dire aux gens c'est quoi leur stats si
tu commences à dire aux gens si tu fais
tel niveau de cliquer tu vas voir tel
incitatifs financiers je trouve que tout
joue un jeu très dangereux est ce que
j'ai j'ai étudié pour les lecteurs et
les lecteurs les auditeurs sont déjà au
courant ça plusieurs fois que le dit
mais j'ai étudié sur le nouveau
journalisme aux états unis des années 60
raconte thérèse thompson entre autres
qui était mon bon journaliste sûr lequel
j'ai fait ma maîtrise puis à cette
maîtrise intéressante homme seul
j'étudiais rose son premier son premier
bouquin en fait j'ai étudié comment ils
y avaient placé la personne n'a
d'intérêt sgs-thomson qu'on a vu plus
tôt arrivé lors de son premier récit
bref à ce moment là les journaux
bénéficier du d'un
financement énormes grâce à des revenus
publics machine un générique énorme
énorme s'y intéressent thompson 10 fois
ils se faisaient données tier 1 15 mille
dollars de l'époque le fait qu'on se
replace en 1960 pour aller couvrir telle
affaire y aller là il fait en bétonnant
draghi revenait pi i le journal des
bombes est ce que te fait c'est pas bon
le publie poppy qu'un veau 6 15 lille
pour la prochaine à force effective et
des trucs complètement incroyable qui
permettait justement aux journalistes de
ne pas être
attiré par la nouvelle rapide puis parle
j'ai besoin de sortir telle affaire qui
va pogner pour vendre des copies
l'espèce de l'équivalent du clic comme
on peut parler aujourd'hui
si tu dis que vous à la presse de ne pas
payer au clic
comment est-ce que tu entrevoit ce shift
médiatique l'a alors que les journaux et
les médias et retient commence à manquer
de ceux de ces revenus là pour pouvoir
justement engager des journalistes de
qualité qui vont incapable de ne pas
travailler au clic ne pas tomber dans
cette espèce de pierre jeunet et que est
ce que les médias doivent faire des
clips devait être lue répond sous le feu
donc que tous sachent ce que tes
lecteurs aiment comme entreprise de
presse ce correct parce que tu es si tu
vois pas qu'ils aiment beaucoup le
jardinage ben plus que le boulingrin se
met deux gosses au boulingrin mais passe
toujours quelque chose que tu comprends
moi le lieu où
les patrons savent combien de clients en
général gimli combien de temps mais je
suis lui ils le savent ce que je dis
c'est moi je veux pas savoir que le
sacha des à des fins d'allocation des
ressources à des fins de
de marketing tant mieux korek mois comme
journaliste je veux pas le savoir parce
que je veux pas commencer à tomber là
dedans quand je trippe sur un sujet je
veux pouvoir plonger dans ce sujet là en
me disant
sans avoir à mener ils vont simuler
ouvrons tu ne peux pas me lire pis
l'autre fait que la notoriété qui est
intéressant c'est que des fois de par la
notoriété ça s'peut qui me lisent même
sur un sujet qui ne leur plaît pas au
début tu es un supporter à nîmes mais je
ne suis pas naïf non plus je pense pas
que je pense pense pas que les médias ne
devrait pas s'intéresser à ce je pense
les médias devraient pas mettre de
pression sur les journalistes pour lier
leur rémunération par exemple ou leur
statut dans notre meilleur au clic
est-ce que tu as le contrôle absolu des
sujets oui ok mais toi ce que tu es ce
que tu constates dans une position quand
même privilégie en tant que journaliste
d'avoir contrôle des sujets que je suis
dans le
top
10 15 des journées les plus choyés au
québec est ce que tu penses que c'est
que ça va durer c'est ce que tu pense
qu'il va avoir de la place moi je
l'espère évidemment mais ce que tu
penses de voir la place poreuse pour le
journalisme comme ceux où est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de pain oui puis regarde moi
j'ai cette notoriété mais t'es pas
obligé d'avoir de la notoriété pour
avoir cette autonomie prends je donne un
exemple
independent et je suis pas un bon jour
nest au québec tom gerber thomas est à
radio canada c'est un reporter pas sûr
que ces boss lui disait thomas
aujourd'hui se recouvrir ce pourquoi
parce que tu as mozena démarche est
comme ça en générant ses propres sujets
la meilleure façon d'être dépendante des
bosses pour les sujets de te faire dire
ce va couvrir sa c2 pas générer de
nouvelles têtes imposant salle de
rédaction ne sort jamais rien bon on va
dire écoute tu vas aller couvrir la
conférence de presse x
tant mieux le juge personne mais c'est
plus fun de génériques est propre sujet
à la presse
tous fait en collégialité site couvre le
bit santé puis aujourd'hui une grosse
annonce où on on va annoncer qu'on
injecte 1 milliard prime pour ramener
des infirmières dans le réseau si c'est
ton beat la santé aujourd'hui de course
mais après demain peut générer ses
propres sujets les salles de rédaction
qui fonctionne le mieux ce sont les
salles de rédaction je pense où les
journalistes sont sont encouragés à
fouiller leur propre sujet générer leur
propre sujet
ça fait des journées sont plus motivés
généralement mais je me regarde dans
l'écosystème jeunes liberté de ton une
liberté de ponctualité c'est à dire que
je livre mes chroniques un joli livre et
puis choisit les sujets sur lesquels je
décide d'écrire c'est un luxe absolu
une position très envie récents via
lesquels après justement tu avais pas
cette pression là puisque nous épater
les chiffres métier on sent que je
trouve qu'il ya certains médias qu'on le
sent quand même que l'idiot une pression
du moins qui tire clairement de vue des
gens d'apt et leur style allait
justement le changement des formules
c'est des gens qui je pense maintenant
de mathieu bock côté quand j'ai commencé
à lire il écrivait des l'ontt exploré
vraiment fouilles étaient vraiment dire
le support l'on puisse faire est nuancée
aussi puis c'est plus du tout l'été je
ne sais vraiment pas vraiment changé
depuis maintenant six cecos et punché
ccc plus et plus camper dans une
position très petit peu dommage qu'on
ait perdu et que j'étais chaque média
son format compris après ça comment
comment qui est payé comme un je ne sais
pas j'entends des trucs je sais qu'il ya
des médias puis je parle pas juste du
québec où les gens sont payés au clic -
ce que je dis c'est encouragent une
polarisation quand il
déclare seulement puis on le veut on le
voit bien en fait on le voit bien dans
le climat actuel
quand tu te retournes sur pied ta
carrière qui
loin d'être terminée mais qui gèle qui
est déjà longue lune c'est moi je me
rappelle aussi longtemps que je suis
l'actualité et existent dans
le monde médiatique moi j'ai 30 ans
affecté j'ai commencé à suivre sur
peut-être j'ai pas
2005 le dôme est arrivé à la presse
c'est exact et fait aussi longtemps je
me rappelles tu existais dans un climat
médiatique c'est quoi les plus gros
changements que tu as vu dans les médias
j'imagine que les médias sociaux ça a
été un homme comme révolution et que je
vais y aller en vrac d'abord
l'effritement les revenus il va enfin
lui qui les médias navigue ram pour
maintenir une base de revenus ce qui a
impliqué de faire des choix
couper des postes
faire des choix rédactionnels qui se
faisait pas avant c'est avant un journal
ça couvrait tout mon nom au couvent [ __ ]
ou pis
c'est plat l'époque a changé mais je
pense que c'est au final si dramatique
que ce
donc les revenus après ça les médias
sociaux mais l'époque numérique moi j'ai
connu la fin de l'époque où
la fin de l'époque où il y en avait pas
de l'internet dans la salle de rédaction
cachet revu au droit au journal ledroit
97 y avait un poste internet derrière le
chef de pupitre c'est un vieux mac il
devait dater du début des 90 puis je
dresse et s était rudimentaire
l'année d'après on a commencé à hornu
des formations internet comment ça
marche on avait l'internet à notre poste
c'est une sorte de révolution donc
internet les médias sociaux ont accéléré
le fait que les médias traditionnels ne
soient plus les seuls à générer de la
nouvelle ça aussi c'est un gros
changement mais en même temps je trouve
que ça ça ça a donné
ça fait prendre conscience à beaucoup de
gens que des gens qui sont payés huit
heures par jour pour faire de
l'information sans de valeur pour la
société gibbs a rappelé à ses sacs des
gens qui font ça à temps partiel sur
seulement les sujets qui les intéressent
et que je dirais les revenus puis tout
ce qui est numérique
ce ça changer beaucoup de choses
moi quand je faisais les faits divers au
journal de montréal
99 environ
trouver une famille qui la famille d'une
victime par exemple des protagonistes
qui avait été impliquée dans un fait
divers dans un événement hors de
l'ordinaire
c'est compliqué enceintes et des heures
au téléphone à gratter un nom avez vous
un numéro téléphone aujourd'hui je
voudrais ça prend une heure 'pitot' les
gens dévoile tout sur les médias sociaux
ça a beaucoup changé ce qui ce qui ce
qui était la vie privée ce qui est l
intimité avant ne l'est plus forcément
aujourd'hui c'est aussi ça a changé de
métier beaucoup ouais parce que
maintenant tout le monde parce que
c'était plus compliqué mais ton moi je
les intranets kg pas internet c'est plus
compliqué d'écrire que j'ai pas aimé ta
chronique le flou que oui que j'écrive
une lettre faut que je te l'envoie par
la poste faut que tu la reçoive son
bureau qu'il faut quand tu es fâché faut
que tu aies du papy way fallait que tous
les cris fin octobre ses voeux un thème
fallait pas que tu oublies de la mettre
dans boîte à malle
ans de ta colère ils craignent un coup
d'oeil à beaucoup d'eau qui coule avait
plusieurs étapes il pouvait être disons
aujourd'hui c'est immédiat ça fait
longtemps que c'est immédiat ce qui a
changé c'est moi j'ai toujours travaillé
que cette immédiateté
quand j'ai commencé à craindre que
j'aurais demandé le courriel évidemment
exister parce que changer c'est que tout
le monde une tribune avant tu m'écris
vais peut-être que tu me confiait ce que
tu pensé de la chronique maintenant la
plupart déjà vos paumes écrivons les
crises vont
exactement donc sur leur page facebook
ou dans une section commentaires etc ce
soc pour moi c'est du bruit faut que tu
te laisses vos partys laisse distraire
c'est incroyable la surabondance
d'opinion qui le suit partout maintenant
vous avant c'était justement un métier
réservé aux chroniques à roter rouge en
installant tout le monde me pignon
surtout puis en ayant noyé là dedans ça
autrement on est on est noyé là bas
mais moi j'ai vu j'ai vu un recentrage
des médias aussi sur plus de requêtes
vous partez quand les gens moi quand les
jambes des gradins d'un média maintenant
juste de l'opinion j'ai fait une
entrevue a pas très longtemps qu'un
crime disait quelqu'un dire basta
maintenant il ya beaucoup trop de pays
beaucoup trop d'opinion ok il ya plus
d'opinions cela je pourrai jamais pu
signer personne là dessus mais retourne
d'un journaux de 1997 le tour des
journaux de 2000 madiana fans l'enquêté
privilégie où nous dit aujourd'hui dans
les médias sont dans une lutte pour le
contenu exclusif parce que c'est ce qui
le distingue de d'ajustement de tous les
bruits qui existe des fois je retourne
la nostalgie un sait jamais une bonne
conseillère c'est vrai pour tes
relations personnelles ton ancienne
blonde avec qui tu aies pu des fois tu
dis à mon justel phone 7 femmes et des
fois c'est de la nostalgie quand ton
époque de second baptisé metal mecha
mode mais non mais t'as passé beaucoup
de temps dans ton seul
seul t'emmerder aussi ça mais enfin
d'information m'emmener et pas longtemps
je fin d'exercice surtout nous dans
l'édition dans des éditions de la presse
jeudi à peu près 87 88
crises que cette plainte non je dis y'a
pas un rapport qui sortait qui n'était
pas l'objet d'un texte de 1500 mots qui
était peu susceptible de faire la une
que je me demande qui lisait ça et
c'était très institutionnel de gizeh la
presse que s'ils avaient jamais personne
dans la rue il y avait très peu de gens
du vraiment qui témoignait c'était
souvent très institutionnel un des seuls
qui est résulté un défaut de lire
qui sortait son calepin qu'ils allaient
parlait du vraiment sinon des officiels
des pdg des ministres et sous ministres
des maires des conseillers tous ces gens
là étaient interviewés mais la vraie vie
était beaucoup moins dans les médias
qu'elle peut l'être aujourd'hui donc
justin long et onéreux mais là on est
dessus virez le lot de bogues trop loin
ce qui
ce qui démarque les médias j'apprends ce
que deux marques les médias
crédibles aujourd'hui justement c'est
leur crédibilité et leur rigueur c'est
l'exactitude des affaires d'horizon
qu'on y retrouve qui justement que l'on
commence à se rendre compte à qui n'ont
et qui ça ça peut être dangereux
justement joblo qui écrit n'importe quoi
sur n'importe quoi sans évoquer le sujet
pis les médias traditionnels lyon la
plupart
se soucie l'ubs c'est de voir le
d'exactitude cirque et maintenant il est
plus pertinent que jamais ce qui vient
avec pour beaucoup de gens
avec une certaine dose de frustration je
te donne raison
car elle était 2020 sa fille en arrière
fait cesser ces
dénonciations sur instagram à propos de
marc pillas mort et les médias reçoivent
ce que sur soi ce jeudi premièrement je
peux pas juste prendre soin puis médecin
à la une du journal de montréal de la
presse du devoir
comme média tu peux pas faire ça une
obligation de vérification de
l'obligation d'essayer de parler à
toutes les parties impliquées comme
safia comme maripier morin mais moi je
me souviens que le lendemain sa fille
anna l'un d'eux peut-être pas la main
staut et même le jour même sa fille ne
rêve exprimé sa frustration du fait que
les médias traditionnels n'est pas en
avait pas de donner écho à ces
révélations
on peut pas faire ça
notre job notre force c'est de vérifier
de confirmer ou infirmer les bruits de
publier des affaires dont on a
vérifié la véracité ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'on se trompe pas mais je me
souviens que autour de sa finale et y
avait beaucoup de gens qui disent eh ben
oui les médias ils font pas leur job non
pas des poursuites coutts est patente
pas des poursuites que de vouloir
dire des choses qui sont vraies hélas sa
fillette dans mon souvenir il
se peut que je m'en charge en quelques
détails mais sa fille anna l'un disait
quand il s'agit de parler de mon
habillement à l'adisq l'heure les médias
sont là oui évidemment
on le voit tinchant des de gerry boulet
on écrit qu'un chalet de gerry boulet
moi c'est pas mon truc quand je
n'écrirai pas là dessus ça m'intéresse
pas il ya des médias qui ont beaucoup
écrit là tu supportes un chalet de jazz
est mal fait avant le voit facilement
vérifiable quant à l'img quelque chose
comme ça
comme média puis je comprends que pour
les personnes qui sont pas versés dans
comment fonctionne le journaliste ça
peut être frustrant dans une haie
membres tout est immédiat mais ça se
fait que la presse en parle pas que si
on veut vérifier parce que dans cinq ans
c'est pas la page instagram dont on va
se répliquent les surtout dans story de
24 heures exactes sur ça va être je
posais oublié mais dans le cas de sa
fille a justement fait un boom soit pas
oublié mais dans cinq ans c'est dans la
presse qu'on va aller voir ce qui s'est
dit dans la presse qu'on qu'on va
vérifier a commencé et ai dit à quel
moment donc un devoir de vérifier puis
plus que jamais quand le monde et dans
l'immédiateté com/media faut toujours
leur applique notre job c'est de publier
des trucs qui sont vrais et ça c'est
plus important qu'avec le premier public
oui c'est pour ça que justement c'est
un travail comme l'a fait le devoir je
te manquer pour rester dans la même dans
même période puis dans le même mouvement
le méthyle de voir qu'il y avait
peut-être aussi sur julien lacroix ne
triplettes avaient tout un travail
journalistique avait été fait qu'elle
rencontre et je pense neuf victimes ça
ça tombe qui je suis au csii et 11 sans
équivoque ne voudriez pas de doute à
guyot delà du travail qui était clair
versus un témoignage anonyme qui sort
sur instagram puis ça fait plaisir qui
est pas vrai mais il ya quand même entre
les deux il ya quelque chose qui est que
plus weepu sa
liste en bas sont différents puis ce qui
veut pas dire que les gens qui publient
du contenu sur instagram au pot leur
utilité il y avait des enquêtes
journalistiques qui partent de ce qui
part dans les médias sociaux donc moi je
méprise pas ça du tout jusque le
standard est différent pissos
ya peut-être un travail de pédagogie de
notre part
j'ai lu la
chronique et a fait sur
le docteur dont j'oublie le nom la danse
au son entrevue et qui avait faire
avec leur marché dr marchand il ya comme
un entrevue vraiment qui est sortie si
je pense début septembre
qui avaient été rip et puis qui avait
été mis sur youtube sur une plate forme
je sais pas exactement le page du taux
de kiel mais j'imagine c'est une
plateforme peu conspirationnistes movie
l'entrevue dans le fond c'était un
profiter de la santé immunologue qui
expliquait que pourquoi les
professionnels de santé avaient une
réticence à se faire vacciner puis moi
tu vois on m'a envoyé une mise ami qui
est un peu là dedans puis il m'a envoyé
cette pensée cette entrevue le sait
quand c'est sorti moi je l'écouté j'ai
fait avant et je sais pas trop quoi dire
la sicile opinions des deux galas au
même titre que
d'autres de l'opinion je mens du dr
les quinze places 5 j étais en cause de
lakovic ou quelque chose comme ça
exemple je porte pas plus attention que
ça finalement ta chronique sort puis là
dans la chronique j'apprends que c'était
une entrevue finalement qui avait été
fait en février au début de la
vaccination qui était grippé puis remis
en ligne en septembre mais qui était
indiqué nulle part pris complètement
hors contexte puis je me rappelle en
lisant ça m'a dit c'est à ça que ça sert
le journalisme de qualité tu sais ce que
ça soit parce que sinon il n'y a rien
qui va d'abord chaque sortie je
comprends ce que tu dis
mais c'est chez les gens qui qui ont
partagé cette entrevue lors qu'ils
étaient un peu tronqué qui étaient
publiés qui été republié en fait à une
époque complètement différente 110 ch en
marchant au moment où ça ça circule en
septembre cette entrevue l'oeil et
vaccinés et double vacciner vaccinés
depuis longtemps et a parlé l'origine à
son chalet pour les maudits qui a été
vaccinée terrain lui entretenait à
l'époque de l'entrevue avec paul arcand
des doutes mais même là il dit et ce jeu
les précaires dans le papier mais je
crains aucun secret quand il me dit ça
il dit wang zhijun peut il chantait
asperger fait que tu me pose une
question je te réponds ce qui est ce qui
peut sembler à être une bonne politique
oui mais pas tout le temps des fois il
faut que plus anticipé comment ça va
être rejoint donc ça va te forcer à
faire des nuances
ajouter des bémols qui ajouterait
peut-être lui humblement me dit écoute
j'ai pas vu comment ça peuvent être
récupérées t ta job depuis 40 ans et
d'être microbiologiste-infectiologue thé
dans son laboratoire avec les
microscopes des éprouvettes et cetera
je sais pas qui a tout un écosystème de
désinformation ne sait pas que tu restes
de jouer leur jeu sans le savoir ce pas
ta job avec lui tu allais dire ça de
bonne foi
puis quand ils regardent dans le
rétroviseur il voit comment il a été
utilisé mais puis
je pense que les riches en marchant dans
20 ans vont une beaucoup plus habile à
contourner disons-le et les pièges plus
les mines puis parce que moi je me
rappelle qu'on appelle à caen jusqu'en
je m'étais fait envoyer sur
juste avoir reçu du revers la même plus
jamais y avoir pensé aux médias c'est un
professionnel qui a 10 cm au final après
j'en ai reparlé même dans des
conversations peut avoir cette
impression le dif est également hors
contexte serait tellement été mieux
certaines conversations que j'ai eues
dans des groupes d'amis d'un métier je
suis content d'avoir fait cette
chronique je pense que ça peut-être
dégonfler un peu ce mythe là mais les
gens qui croisent
ils n'ont pas arrêté d'y croire mais non
c'est seulement grâce parce qu'il évoque
les gens croient ce rendu là utilisent
plus vraiment peut-être mais ils veulent
croire c'est aussi un élément que je te
dis veulent croire il ya tellement de
fois dans le conspirationnisme
qui est dur à détricoter est ce que
c'est quelque chose mais tant le
conspirationnisme élargissons le plus
largement que juste là coville est dans
la situation actuelle est quelque chose
que toi tu as vu dans ta carrière qui
existait avant ou c'est comme ça ça sort
de nulle part dans cette situation là je
suis 0 étonné oui
en 2001 il ya eu les attentats et dans
les années qui ont suivi
commencez à grande et bien
prospéré sur le web toute une nébuleuse
de conspirationnistes les trotters
c'est les mêmes mécanismes qui sont à
l'oeuvre présentement sauf que avec les
médias sociaux c'est comme si tu leur as
20 g injecté ces mouvances là une dose
de stéroïdes
donc je suis zéro et année puis moi ça
fait longtemps que je parle de ces
fausses croyances de désinformation j'en
parlais avant la pandémie j'en parlais
quand une charge de caudan universités
disait des choses qui étaient
complètement folle
je te faisais peur d en ruine ou ta part
oui je voyais un potentiel
pas de déstabilisation mais mais mais de
pollution d esprit et
dans notre métier lui rejoint là dessus
a rejoint là dessus il disait des choses
qu'ils disaient jutra uniquement dans
des forums de discussion peu
fréquentables enfin maintenant on fait
que je pourrais pas surpris du
cc autre que moi j'te mac qui confronté
à ce jeu
bush a fait nommer wendel entendu mes
chutes et protégez pas je me suis pas
penché sur la question [ __ ] et les
pyramides ont été faits par les
extraterrestres aussi ces choses là on
n'a pas marché sur la lune n'a pas
marché sur la lune le cancer a été
guérie mais ils vont ni veut le poste
pas ça fait trop d'argent ces choses là
j'ai entendu mais j'en ai je dit ça mais
j'ai jamais été confronté à ça on est là
c'est la première fois dans ma vie où
est ce que je confrontés à ceux où est
ce que on dirait que c'est si c'est
comme tout match pompe pour
juste rester informé sur c'est quoi la
dernière affaire oui oui en fait tu as
fait tu sais je parlais de religion je
m'arrête fois tantôt pour poursuivre
tout ça fortin et les moeurs quasiment
religieux faut que tu tombes la bandit
je note et que je m'étais fait réflexion
dans avec les trotters un que je me fais
présentement un gros événement qui
bouleverse
l'imaginant qui bouleverse les individus
plein de gens de bonne foi qui veulent
soudainement s'informer qu'il n'avait
pas fait tant que ça ok je suis un
portrait type évidemment que des gens
hyper informés qu'ils sont tombés là
dedans c'est un portrait type mais moi
je retrouve des archétypes de personnes
maintenant dans la pandémie que je
retrouvais après
des gens qui veulent comprendre le monde
mais ils ont 35 ans puis commence à
s'intéresser à un seul je te le dis sans
aucun mépris
christique le mans
c'est un endroit complexe qu'on arqués
et kt et ya 20 ans le soudainement le
faut que tu comprennes comment
fonctionne le moyen-orient christie a
des mots et des gens qui font des
doctorats qui ont été diplomate dans ces
endroits là qu'ils comprennent pas
encore comment ça marche le te deum
d'audit des milliers de personnes
effrayées qui commencent à s'intéresser
à comment ça fonctionne en irak en
arabie saoudite
en egypte
comment fonctionne l'islam se situent
dans des enjeux extrêmement complet quoi
se perdre mais c'est la même chose avec
avec la pandémie il ya de quoi se perdre
dans une science qui est des fois
incertaine qui donne pas des réponses
claires et des gourous qui ne te donne
des réponses super clair c'est rassurant
on
sait aussi que la manière dont on
s'informe puis on va chercher
l'information était justement tout le
web dont ddv tantôt ces six nouveaux
pieds l'apparition de youtube
l'apparition d'un blog l'apparition de
toute affaire le ou est-ce que n'importe
qui peut publier ce qu'ils veulent c'est
puis on n'a pas été formés c'est cette
génération n'est autre qu'une personne
était formée sur le comment reconnaître
qu'une source est fiable ou non et je
dirais jamais personne qui nous a dit si
tu touches à quelque chose c'est
l'essentiel comment commence à boiter
dans une personne ne nous a jamais dit
non kiev 10 août et qu'un article du new
york times atteint plus de valeur
objective qu'un vidéo youtube mais tenté
mais
quand je vous dis que j'en parlais avant
la pandémie tête eu beaucoup de
désinformation à travers
tout ce qui touchait les migrants les
religions comme l'islam les gens m'en
voyez des sources d j'exagère à peine
une source qui exige qu'ils n'existent
que sur facebook le site s'appelle et
c'est possible mais tout con parce que
jeudi les musulmans vont nous manger
points comme le ton mais ça s'était
présenté comme la vérité pourquoi parlez
pas de tueur c'est quoi la source cette
littératie médiatique elle est à faire
parce que j'étais moi c'est ça ma job
depuis 25 ans c'est quoi la source
savait pas et que je me trompe pas mais
je met pas sur le même pied le new york
times avec un journal que je connais pas
et que j'essaie de voir tu m'envoies une
source au journal que je connais pas
donc jamais entendu parler je veux voir
ce qu'un journal légitime mais sur
facebook tout ce vous pisse et
encourager parce que une chose qui est
encouragé sur les médias sociaux par les
algorithmes c'est l'engagement qu'est ce
qui pourrait vous que l'engagement de la
colère la nuance avec beaucoup moins
d'engagement fait le site qui s'appelle
les musulmans vont vous mangez point com
et en suscitant maudit de l'engagement
enfin que l'algorithme ivotel l'envoyer
bill va l'envoyer à toutes tes amis ceci
comme tu es sur facebook n'importe quel
article va se partager peu importe la
source va sensiblement voir dans la
maman fait une brit hôtel type qui en
petit en dessous de 6 ans c'est le rl
compliqué on disait que si c'est un
article plus cliquer plus cliquez dessus
plus je vis quelque chose on dirait dans
leur et dans le cerveau de bain demande
si c'est quelque chose qui a été écrit
sadique et ça ça doit être oui on est
alors avoir été checkés
même chose avec même chose et que les
vidéos youtube
après tu peux de créer un environnement
dans ton seul qui va ressembler un
studio de rdi entre 2,6 et même un fake
pour les gens c'est la même affaire que
de l'info fait par des vrais
journalistes
je voulais je voulais qu'on parle parce
que j'ai fait une
je fais souvent des soirées où est ce
que je regarde des vidéos avec des amis
des vidéos genre haute school du québec
cd des trucs qui sont passés à tvck
élections comme des moments marquants
qui ont marqué l'imaginaire puis il ya
un épisode des francs tireurs à skis
tout tu vas voir un gars le avec son
chat le ghetto
logement j'avais vu ce jeu les oubliés
pendant 15 ans pierrick âge les revues
ça m'a ramené de suite quand j'ai vu ce
sont
des moments de même on peut parler de ce
moment en particulier le aubin des
moments bien dans ta carrière qui
j'imagine qu'il y en a qui restent
auquel tu repenses des fois puis fait
comme si ça se peut pas que ça me soir
il se sait dans le top 5 3 ça se voit
dans ta farce excellente chose qui est
en train d'être marqué à tout jamais
tu vois tu fais qu'un tramway
pour la petite équipe aussi tuer les
gens ont faim spéciales autos aux
frontières ça tire dans toutes les
directions métier on
je pense qu'on a luc ferrandez qui nous
livre sa vision de toppi plein d'aspects
touché qui toucha à la place de l'auto
dans nos vies pilar les recherchistes
découvre un gars
qui lui trip sur son charme est vraiment
fait venir des pièces du japon
le gomme modifier son loto la tête du
tuning
le volant et pas à gauche et à droite
beaucoup beaucoup de soin sur la
peinture des impôts
mais accueillaient une relation
particulière avec son char tian les
camps les recherchistes amène ce gars là
est ce qui te l'amène en dix ans que
l'ess et justin pas signé d'un passionné
de pièces pid un tripeux vraiment et
trip son char bayod six tasses pelo qui
suit présente je m'en souviens pas mais
elles auront certainement vérifier
elles auront au moins incertaine disons
un avant goût de l'amour charnel qui
serait l'homme pour son chant avec leur
jeu en entrevue avec lui
mais il parle de son char comme comme do
leblon pim 10 des affaires à cacv métal
le corps sa seule qualité c'est qu'elle
peut pas me faire des affaires sexuelles
1 son seul défaut est son se dit que je
me rappelle pas de tout ce qui dit le
juge je paraphrase vu récemment un
avantage sur moi mais là il me dit
tellement d afin qu'ils sont énormes que
m'emmener ça on ne l'a pas montré ce que
je pense pas
j'arrête là un truc je dis oh que je dis
ok j'ai attendu comme le continuer à
filmer que je regarde la gueule et que
tu me fais
c'est beaucoup trop énorme ton amour
pour ton charles c'est là ça pas de sens
juste un amour charnel cassidy et je
pense qu'ils pensent qu'il va il pensa
seule soirée we did m j'aime mon à tous
pour le sens figuré exact avec l'âge je
lui dis je regarde parce que
le compte en train de filmer on va pas
le diffuser mais regarde je te dis que
j'ai des gros doutes sur ce que tu me
dis dans mon souvenir il se fâche nom
julien et spock c'est vrai oui
exact je dis regarde c'est un mini
caméra ici tu nous fais puis quand on
voit le diffuser tu voudrais regardait
stick je les ai eus les frontières moi
je ressorti ce total plus pour dire que
ce que je m'en avait des gros doutes
finalement il s'assume est au bout de
ses sorties le mercredi soir s'assumer
encore et non ne faites quelque chose
qui se faisait pas beaucoup à l'époque
on a pris un but mais si je me trompe
pas le jeu les mis sur mon blog
et ça s'est mis à circuler sur des blogs
et même sur twitter qu'ils étaient
ballottés au même si
l'oeil a pas aimé ça
la laine demandé de retirer ça parce que
le soudainement
déjà envoyé sa tv il faut que tu
appelles ton ami plutôt chic ça c'était
avant que toutes disponibles sur le web
facilement tc d'un premier de revenir au
québec mais
un peu maintenant mail à l'oeil c'est
sûr mais plus sûr c'était complètement
fou je m'en rappelle comme si c'était
hier mais sa part dans le sens strauss
quelqu'un qu'on regarde cette ct plage
vous on est des amis qu'on a fait même
du bape perfecto fils et moi c'est
vraiment à face deux gars qui ne
saisit pas
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
je me mets frits je me méfie ps je pense
qu'ils sont en train de me prendre on a
six ans qu'il ya quelqu'un qui qui qui
s'est dit que voici une occasion de
faire mal paraître démission l'a
donc le chemin jcrois pop 2 sur mes
gardes que peint des affaires exposants
matin
puis il ya nos tuteurs des moments comme
ça mais il hésite et aux forts en
émotion conspirationnistes qui est 2006
juste dans ma deuxième saison des
francs-tireurs je pense là les mouvances
conspirationnistes le las a commencé à
vraiment monter et on est allé un
congrès de conspirationnistes à
sherbrooke beaucoup beaucoup de twitter
du 11 septembre
moi j'avais déjà écrit là-dessus et
quand ça finit que j'ai testé dans le b
de l'hôtel que j'ai été encerclé par des
conspirationnistes assez hostile qui me
bombarder de questions fait que gt gt
comme j'étais comme le paratonnerre puis
j'étais obligé de répondre à toutes
leurs questions c'est un dossier que je
connaissais bien mais ça avait été très
très intenses est-ce que c'était filmé
sur wii c'est filmé ou l'effexor on
avait en effet diffusé dans le mois un
moment où est ce que tout le monde te
poser questions en lien avec leur projet
de coin will sur le riz septembre 8
exact fait que
le fait que les francs tireurs pour cela
il ya eu beaucoup de moments pas
forcément comme semer métal est la
rencontre de gens qui qui qui qui était
souvent aux marges aujourd'hui les
marges sont rendus dans le centre la
boîte en fait c'est parce qu'ils sont
très bruyants à l'époque c'était moins
présent que les frères scène d'opéra
plongeurs beaucoup de l'univers comme
c'était pas la compétence et une salle à
8 à 8 ans -18 600 serveurs à huy joueurs
rejoignent j'ai beaucoup aimé faire ça
beaucoup de thé quale les quelque chose
que tu mènes simpson la variété la
variété de fond et de forme
j'aime tous les projets que je fais
mettez deux amendes en c1 chaussée des
entrevues les francs tireurs
ce faisant notre but est qu'ils étaient
je pensais que tu devrais faire un 16
minutes en ondes avec ce finalement
l'invité pardonner beaucoup
s'ouvrait se confiait ont plaisir à
baisser de quoi ont fait 40 minutes les
trois-quarts de l'émission
donc cette variété là d'aller sur le
terrain aussi on faisait des voyages et
c'est un format qui était qui était
vraiment le fun à faire j'ai vraiment
aimé se découvrit j'ai beaucoup de
nostalgie par rapport à ceux qui
j'imagine qu'elle assiste en garde un
bon souvenir en fait tu as écrit à
martine est ce que
je me dis tu es d'accord et on va parler
mais titre déçus qui aujourd'hui mettant
votre relation et pascal a été comme un
cadet tout commence à tourner ou bien
vous êtes rue de tourner la page puis
c'est la vie publique est pas déçu non
non
je te déçu comme parce qu'à cette époque
la machine qui est
un très bon coéquipier tu vas
je pense pas que tu vas trouver
quelqu'un qui a travaillé dans les
francs tireurs qui va dire martineau
il est prié pas corrects il ya des gens
à showbiz dont on vote 0,7 et qui sont
pas toujours gentil le chat c'est un
coéquipier je suis pas le fond super
agréable rien entre nous nos différences
ça ne va pas de plonger la dame c'est
plate pour tout le monde mais c'est sont
venus après un prêt du matériel mais je
garde un bon souvenir de lui comme
coéquipier tu sais quand je pense à un
chat comme coéquipier des francs tireurs
je me dis pas c'est un substrat pas du
tout quitter sans rentrer dans les
détails de votre relation à vous parce
que c'est ça vous regarde vous mettrez
qu'est ce qu'est ce que tu penses que
c'est passé il y as tu changé comme le
montre son fils et des pôles où c'est le
monde qui a changé puis lui qui est pas
changé ou si où est ce que maintenant
ils rendus à un personnage qui s'assume
complètement là dedans ou
vraiment tout ce qu'écrit il assume
qu'il parle juge et que je suis pas dans
sa patte gauche poche pendant sa tête
moi je les ai vus me faire ce qu'il veut
faire d'autre
mon principal reproche à l'échangé c'est
pas ce qu'il pense des enjeux c'est
parce qu'il pense des individus c'est la
caricature qu'il fait des individus et
des enjeux et après ils attaquent cette
caricature
que je partage un bon tweets sur ce
aujourd'hui exactement ouais c'est ce
que j'ai dit aujourd'hui j'ai partagé un
tweet que j'envoyais 5 1 et quelques en
fait je partage ce que j'ai écrit une
capture d'écran de ce que j'ai écrit et
de l'interprétation kerichard en fait
c'est comme si je te disais ton vin et
du bon
roi mais quand on vient pas l'air bon
thème le vin pas bon mais c'est bien car
ouais mais c'est pas du vin et de la
bière mais les gens qui les gens en fait
même pas comme je te le disais c'est
comme si je devais appeler le monde et
double coûteuse ilbo et bois ibb wert l
alcool puis
puis je trouve que c'est car boire de
l'alcool car si c'était même postale
colloque était en train de boire de la
bière j'ai compris mon reproche à
richard c'est de dénaturer caricatures
et des positions des des adversaires
d'attaquer la caricature moi quand je
lis richard qui dit quelque chose
quelqu'un je veux voir la source je me
fie pas aux faits qui valent paraphraser
jeu il ya fait quelque chose à daniel
wayne stocks qui est un intellectuel
professeur université que want it up fin
de conférence très nuancé un moment
donné où il était question
de
mutilation génitale il pas de nuances
avoir sur le principe de la mutilation
génitale la nuance de woodstock c'est
quand il racontait le raisonnement de
certains médecins face à sow est ce
qu'on dénonce commandes dénonce est-ce
qu'il faut dénoncer il se mettait dans
leur tête pour expliquer le raisonnement
de ces médecins là et c'est très clair
que woodstock était résolument est
définitivement contre l'excision
mais richard au fait d autres choses à
voir en stock et c'est ce qu'il a
dénoncé dans sa chronique il a fait
passer ou un stack pour quelqu'un qui
était
qui avait une certaine dureté
charitablement qui avait une certaine
ouverture face à ça c'était pas vrai tu
regarde la vidéo mais mon dieu je suis
tombé des nues ce c'était de toutes les
femmes de toutes les foires aux charades
dénaturer caricaturer un adversaire et
où une position geste l everest la
caricature mais je suis pas d'accord
avec ce procédé le je trouve que c'est
nocif mais
c'est facile hein c'est facile de faire
ça mais je ne peux pas croire qu'ils
étaient mettons un peu comme lui qu'avec
la carrière que hu
qui le parcours qui a eu qui passe
intelligente pour voir cette nuance
l'admettons dans les propos de woodstock
avec pramac il prend le maquis adsl mais
que ses comptes sip c'est conscient
finalement c'est c'est quelqu'un sur le
jeu
je pense atteindre parce que c'était
d'abord avec des amis souvent pas par
rapport à martine hommes et par rapport
à tout le monde qui fait aimer ton
temujin québec des filion ont tué
compagnie pis tout à la question penses
tu commences qui dit où il va il fait un
show qui fait je sois pour faire un show
si on s'entend jamais je sais pas mais
moi ça m'est arrivé de me faire envoyer
des vidéos
pilule tan aliz la vidéo et le taret de
la vidéo peut tu prends des notes
d'essayer de voir le contexte du pet
chaque mot ça prend du temps face à ça
près
des fois tu va taper toute la job outre
les le rapport tu vas faire l'entrevue
puits afin
crise n'y a pas d'histoire
c'est une salade genre tu vérifies pis
des fois il y en a pas d'histoire
des fois le légal je parle quelqu'un
m'appelle quelqu'un contact je fais des
vérifications que je me dis points et
que seule sa va pas chez
une petite vérification puisque quand
même emmené quand tu mets toutes les
vérifications dans le contexte du gain
mais non j'ai pas d'histoire ne rien
ajouter des fois la job que je fais avec
yves boivin jeudi j'ai fait une erreur
et j'ai vérifié
vigoureux
des fois tu vérifies
ton a priori ça scrap la chronique qui
était déjà en train d'écrire dans ta
tête
mais c'est ce fait que pour les eaux
pour richard t richard ya assez de
talent pour
faire une chronique par jour
sans avoir à faire ce pour quoi il le
fait je sais pas ce que je te dis c'est
moi je vois ça c'est que j'ai parlé d'un
tweet aujourd'hui je parlais des
féministes c'était il ya cinq ans je
faisais je met les pleins d'idées
richard a dit à ben lagacé comparé
féministe à ben laden ouais c'était
juste parce que dans le même paragraphe
y avait le mot féministe et ben
moi tu es dans le même paragraphe mais
évidemment il n'y a pas donné de sources
ans exerce alors il n'y a pas dit que
voici
mais non donc moi je trouve que c'est un
procédé qui parient goût
dans la chronique et a fait je pensais
aujourd'hui ou hier tu parlais de parce
que l'on parle de
peindre une caricature fait ensuite
s'entendre à la caricature tu parlais de
la caricature du wac qui s'est fait dans
les familles à l'assemblée nationale ça
c'était un peu partout en occident car
en cas à saint-georges sûr qu'on va se
retourner sur cette chance cet échange
là à l'assemblée nationale quand votre
maison en disant on va trouver que c'est
la chose la plus absurde
[Rires]
puis je
faisais le parallèle avec avec plein de
plaine causeway ce qu'évidemment que
cette race team je peux prendre le
véganisme comme examen je suivais
gagnent du fil la caricature du vegan
c'est facile de l'attaqué est typique au
final c'est c'est des mouvements qui
sont crédibles pays qui sont nécessaires
même est ce que c'est si cette idée là
de quatre captures et des gens qu'est ce
que tu penses qui est derrière c'est ce
que tu penses que c'est pour attirer
l'intérêt ce que tu penses que c'est
pour mettre des choses complexes dans
des cases simple pour être capable et
compartimentés lisez
ou est ce que tu penses c'est juste la
nature humaine qu'on fait tout le temps
sur caen que c'est une idée qu'on se
pose c'est plus facile de faire un
amalgame de toutes les choses qui sont
extrêmes piles et les pointer du doigt
très bon vieux sophisme c'est l'homme de
paille ou c'est ça depuis toujours on on
est là dedans ça fait partie si je pense
la tentation de quiconque et dans le
débat public
mais encore là une tentation qui guette
tout le monde mais moi c'est pas mon
modèle d'affaires c'est pas mon modus
operandi habituel
il ya bien il ya plein d'éléments de ce
qu'on appelle le mouvement ows qui est
qui est wtf jeudi dé controverse parce
que quelqu'un porte des dreads des
controverses parce que à vous donne des
cours de yoga aps c de l'appropriation
restaurateurs québécois décide de faire
une soirée coréenne puis soudainement il
ya quelques personnes qui lève la main
en disant que c'est de l'appropriation
c'est épouvantable je pense décor 1 cent
contre crise
mais mais mais tout se crée une
impression la fin des livres brûlés en
ontario 1 c'est complètement fou mais ça
veut dire que tout ce qui provient des
milieux dits progressistes qui veulent
une égalité qui cookies qui combattent
l'inéquité raciale
c'est de la merde dans le cc non
mais je lis certains commentateurs de
l'impression queen c'est une façon
réconfortante de décrédibiliser tout un
mouvement
c'est de voir juste la pointe de
l'iceberg oui en fait cessé ses quelques
occasions le qui font les manchettes qui
font des controverses qui dont on parle
longtemps des banques qui chevauche à
quéven demande mais en bout de ligne
c'est juste une minorité de militants
qui je reviens de mai ph à ce moment-là
l'assemblée nationale
c'était pour moi je le vois comme étant
-
what the fuck que vous ces deux
adversaires qui cherchent à se définit
pis ce soir là j'ai l'impression que
gabriel nadeau dubois s'est ouvert une
bonne bière dit yes pourquoi parce que
françois le groupe parle de gabriel
nadeau-dubois le traite comme son seul
adversaire fait peu ou pas ça avec le pq
et avec les libéraux fait et pour la
crainte de gabbana 12 boîtes québec
soldats
le sur un plateau d'argent oui legault
sur mon bateau est l'ennemi à abattre
ils veulent pas abattre les libéraux ils
veulent plus à battre le pq cessé ces
deux ses deux adversaires se sont
définis publiquement ce jour là c'est de
la politique peut faire ça avait l'air
en surface un petit peu
enfantin mais c'est de la bonne vieille
politique je dis pas que c'est une bonne
dépôt de d-box est un bon modèle de
politique mais c'est vieux comme le
monde
en politique je pense jamais à propos
qui disait ça c'est le fait d'avoir des
amis mais ses fans avoir des ennemis et
ses deux ennemis là se sont trouvés
défini pour moi ce jour non les deux
finalement on utilise la même texte
technique parce que tu es on dit qu'il
ya justement
françois govou les caricatures et
gabriel en traitant de broc mais il
espère ce jeudi françois legault un
petit plat sinon plus et south tyne
quelques amis
en effet demandé il ya toujours un
élément de caricatures politiques
c'est évident mais c'est juste le moment
c'est juste d'entendre
wow comme une sci fi de cet apport
dans l'univers de françois legault la
laisse bon quitte une insulte
sa demande c'est quoi un peu son état
d'esprit qu'il varie ben oui
j'avais pas pensé à ce que tu viennes
isère au sujet de 2 depuis le retour à
l'assemblée nationale
on dirait que le le compétiteur majeur
de françois legault c'est gabriel dubois
de tout ce qu'on entend des emp que les
deux parties cop n'allons plus de
députés que québec solidaire on n'entend
rien dire de ces parties là les partis
d'opposition j'écoute
des fois tu l'impression avoir l'espace
que québec solidaire que parce qu'ils
sont bons pour occuper leur temps
l'impression que c'est l'opposition
officielle ne sont pas l'opposition
officielle c'est les libéraux
l'opposition officielle
le pq a à peu près autant députés le
jugement à propos du score final 2 et
ait eu des démissions des défections des
gens qui vont aussi agi comme
indépendants
il y aura peu près le même nombre de
députés que québec solidaire mais
l'espace occupé par québec soldats des
médias sociaux dans les médias points en
chambre il
c'est comme un boxeur
qui est capable de se battre en haut de
son poids fakir quelque chose de
fascinant puis les mauvais la mauvaise
nouvelle lada c'est beaucoup pour le pq
mais c'est de loin la partie qui est le
branding le plus fort tribut quelques
clics il améliore notre promotion puis
utilisation des réseaux sociaux droit
mais après ça tu es réseaux sociaux vers
ce vote maxime bernier pays a augmenté
son score sur l'année pas sur la
dernière élection mais mener le jeu les
blocs est gelée bloqué à dynamite -
surtout étonné les gens du parti
populaire et aurait pu penser que ces
gens là à les traduire leur présence
médias sociaux en vote puis c'est pas
toujours le cas ça c'est pas
parler de sujets délicats par les
radicalisations comment dessus toi là
dedans tu décides
qu'est ce qui t'as un sujet qui est
d'intérêt public ou qu'est ce qu'il
mérite la peine qu est ce que tu t'y à
terme et ont versé quelque chose que tu
sois tutrice crêpes aux studios soient
vos placements bonne question est ce que
ça a une portée universelle
ceux ci avaient trois complétistes au
québec
3 radicaliser gens j'en parlerai pas
mais c'est devenu une sorte de phénomène
de société on peut toujours dire oui
mais regarde sur juste 10% 10 pour sa
puissance mais personne au québec c'est
beaucoup de monde dans un contexte de
pandémie mais les efforts des de la
majorité peuvent être sapée par une
minorité sur t-note quand on parle de
chaînes de transmission puis de
protection du groupe donc il ya tout un
caractère universel
je parle de mon nombril mais je fais
juste parler de mon ombre y pique sans
intérêt juste mon nom brille c'est une
chose si je parle de quelque chose qui
est universel qui concerne mon nom
brille je pense que les gens vont se
reconnaître
mais je donne un exemple 5 celle des
revenus le tombé sur un netflix
j'ai trippé sur cinq fermes mais
vraiment mais le monde s'en contre torch
je vais pas faire une chronique là tu
veux pas faire un segment radio mon
auditoire mon public québécois
francophones jeudi il ya 3 % du monde
sont intéressés par sa donc il n'ya pas
de portée universelle pour moi j'étais
américain j'étais canadiens anglais sera
une autre affaire pour les radicaliser
même sont 10 pour ça que se tisse un
impact majeur dans société parce que ça
annonce aussi à venir en terme de
pollution d'information de la caisse qui
fait mettons que mais tant qu'on parle
justement de 11 personnes et se joue pas
ne s'amarre dire qu'il y en est un mais
qu'est ce qui fait que met-on c'est
parce que coûte a co signé une chronique
sur guillaume lemay thivierge
multiplient qu'est ce qui fait que cette
histoire l'oeil est pas anecdotique puis
en vaut la peine d'être traité mettant
comme écoute le scond ce qu'on ne
déterminait après c'est ton appris la
grid analyses par exemple de gens qui
sont des personnalités publiques qui
vont perdre un contremaître
la comédienne x et dans le téléroman y
c'est pas son rôle
son personnage mans mais en fait parce
que maintenant un nouveau rôle dans un
autre téléroman elle est plus temps de
faire mon veut dire pourquoi guillaume
lemay thivierge c'est connu qu'il avait
ce guiglo de réalisation de stricts
critères y est plus là on l'apprend
pourquoi que déjà là selon les standards
de nouvelles qui touche le showbiz c'est
une nouvelle
après ça
ici italie dans des hôtels dans un
restaurant qui a demandé un traitement
de faveur
et ce traitement de faveur la est
illégal et il demande un accommodement
qui n'est pas légal aujourd'hui c'est
pas juste ce pas illégal d'utiliser sa
célébrité pour dire je dois avoir une
place samedi soir et une heure de vie
d'un restaurant le plus apte en ville
c'est parce que guillaume a fait c'est
pas illégal tu peux le faire non dd je
veux tu muller se rentrer dans ton reste
j'aimerais que tu me laisse entrer dans
ton restera alors que je ne suis pas
vacciné j'ai pas de passeport vaccinale
ben c'est une manne commerçants de faire
quelque chose d'illégal
saucisses et ça participe d'un certaine
intérêts publics
il est clairement contre des mesures
sans doute un saut j'ai pu geler
vérifier moi-même
et ils propagent ces idées là c'est
plate mais quand une personnalité
publique yves des choses que tu fais pas
tu dis qu'ils risquent de devenir
d'intérêt public une influence ne sont
pas pour des gens qui sont pas d'intérêt
public ce sont des quidams il ya des
gens qui nous ont accusés d'avoir
éventé son dossier médical
si une personnalité publique fait un
infarctus puis quand la preuve qu on le
vérifie il est possible qu'on en fasse
une nouvelle alors que c'est un quidam
on va pas le faire c'est le premier
ministre du québec fait une pierre au
rein on voit expliqué qu'il était
hospitalisé pour une pierre au rein pour
luis fait partie d'un certain dossier
médical qui normalement est pas publier
pour la moyenne des ours
si la même façon que si un quidam se
fait arrêter pour alcool au volant qui
est pas connue il ya très peu de chances
que qu'on en parle même sont prêts à
parler si moi je vais faire arrêter pour
elle que l'ovale à ce que je peut pas
plaider que ace car serge et rabelais de
remplir les besoins par les pommes et
moi vous en parler ça fait partie tu
mets c'est donc ces deux éléments le le
contrat perdu pour des raisons qu'on
sait puis demander des traitements
faveur dans un dans un restaurant tout
mais ça ensemble pays dans ma business
ça s'appelle une nouvelle
est-ce que avec
l'expérience en fait je sais pas
peut-être que ça jamais été sur le mais
ce que tu es nerveux des fois quand tu
sors des chroniques ou qu'un tu traite
d'un sujet à x ou y est ce qu est ce qui
m est ton quand tu écris la chronique le
tu l'envoies ton éditeur plus tu sais
que ça sort le lendemain m est-ce que
des fois tu dors moins bien et eu des
fois où ce qui te dis
qu'est ce qui va se passer et
appréhendent la réception et lotus
est-ce que c'était déjà arrivé à est-ce
que c'était déjà arrivé puis ben est ce
que si oui ça paraît vent quand des fois
des fois oui je pense je pense que c'est
bon de doutes et ses cinq buts et
manière vous citez toujours par rapport
la même affaire ma nervosité toujours
sur les faits est ce qu'on s'est trompé
est-ce que je me semble et ce que j'ai
tout vérifié il ya un angle mort est
quelque chose que j'ai oublié de
vérifier
si non sur l'opinion est le même je dois
d'avoir mon opinion ci est basée sur des
faits vérifiables
fait si si ge anticipe que les gens vont
être fâchés parce que j'aime la
hochelaga nano blanc
qui se dit j'aime ce nom est ce qu'on
prend mais
si je disais ah ça c'est une excellente
bien de mots seuls ne danse pas bien de
mons l1 ça c'est ce qui m'empêche
dormait là pas de m'être trompé des fois
c'est pas te tromper sur le fait que des
fois l'appréciation des faits ce ce oui
des fois ça va m'empêcher de dormir wii
semble avoir quand même
une bonne peur delà de la mauvaise
information je lisais dans chronique sur
qui on peut commencer à prendre des
médicaments de la vivent cependant à
papa qui tout a commencé juste de
mélanger l'alaska puis nebraska je
pensais à ce qu'un foulard kenza la
rescue lar kenza fêtes emmené été écrit
par kenza sa place d'alaska puis la sat
en avril dans une spirale où est ce que
tu te disais qu'il y avait un problème
notre cerveau qu'il fallait que tu
règles oui mais seulement ça m'arrive à
tous les jours de l'année de savoir de
me tromper dans quelque chose de faire
mais je sais que je sais que c'était pas
ça m'était pas idée à quel point je sais
que sarah palin gouverneur de l'alaska
no de l'arkansas je sais ça vaudra comme
je sais que je viens de laval votre
emprunt et là je me trompe là tu fais
que j'ai sincèrement pas quelque chose
dans mon cerveau qui marchent pas fait
que je vais avoir le nom europe si de
mon fils puis on fait des tests puis au
bout des tests dits de nant
contrairement à ce que tu penses d'un
déficit d'attention oui la part de
l'erreur est toujours sauf qu'au final
tu finis en zalba faut juste il accepte
parce que l'erreur a amené qui peut pas
tout contrôler tout le temps ça aurait
peut-être été bon quand j'étais au
secondaire
j'aurais peut-être moins rocher j'aurais
pas plus aimer les maths mais j'aurais
moins rocher sur les matches j'ai
souffert de ce
village et plus compris dans cette
aventure quand même mon cerveau
fonctionne et je pense que
je pense que d'avoir pris du vivant ce
au secondaire ça a peut-être été la
différence en avoir 72 72 au final sera
même plus aujourd'hui oui toujours
jamais place aujourd'hui mais j'aurais
moins cher frère à cette époque le toit
d'apprentis maintenant de manière
régulière non non j'en ai pris quelques
semaines à l'été 2010 9 j'ai pas aimé ce
que ça me faisait
pipi le gain d'efficacité je trouvais
pas quitter assez grand pour me taper
les désagréments de cette médication là
ce qui veut pas dire que ça peut pas une
excellent pour plusieurs personnes ce
n'est pas un avis médical
avant contre laisse partir je veux je te
poser une dernière question quelqu'un
qui ont eu une carrière comme la sienne
qui a fait des choix qui a toujours
amené vers un nouveau projet un autre
projet piteuse jamais manqué de travail
ce qui est quelque chose qui est quand
même unique d'antan ton métier
qu'est-ce qui dirige ses choix
quand tu penses à ta carrière tu ici
parce que parce que tu veux mais je
lisais rapidement tonton wikipédia en
français aux avants aujourd'hui enfin
celui qui dit que cheney en france non
non je pense pas qu'il s'agit de changy
bas j'ai peut-être pas au mieux un ou
deux intervieweurs la ph qui sont fait
pogner avec la page wikipédia avait sa
deuxième en externe ni chez paou dans le
sud de la france puis je connais ça se
peut ça se passe à fait mais bon enfant
tu me diras si si si je me trompe dans
ce parcours là mais c'était depuis
tu nous attente au-dessus des chroniques
depuis vraiment jeune mais après si tu
étais rentrer à l'université d'ottawa
pour étudier le journalisme et après ça
toujours été et est toujours un autre
projet toujours notre trajet moyen ski
quescan qu'on me propose un projet c'est
quoi qui dirigent ces choix puis de
quelle façon est ce que mettons pour les
gens qui nous écoutent qui sont
peut-être un peu perdu qui savent pas
vraiment qui ont une passion mais qui
pas trop varroa les tipis et deux phases
la première c'est après l'université
parce que c'est une question que je me
fais poser souvent disons que je fais
une conférence à l'université ou et les
sous qui commence dans le métier ceux
qui sont à l'université ce qui veut
savoir c'est comment on fait pour percer
les premières jobs toujours les plus
difficiles à voir quand un journaliste
établi que je pense pas moi je pense à
des kits qui ont 35 ans mais qui ont un
design métier puis c'est des bons
journalistes
millions d offres de partout à chaque
année comprennent ça c'est pas dur c'est
au début c'est la première job montmeyan
conseil c'est pour ma business pour un
journalisme au début faut que tu en
fasses si tu as la chance de pas avoir
une hypothèque ne pas avoir un enfant
d'avoir à s'occuper d'un proche malade
si la presse tap elle pas ben oui tu
prends la job à chicoutimi et oui tu
prends la job à radio canada
saskatchewan faut que tu aies des heures
de vol au début tu multiplies les heures
de vol
même ses pales fans même si la fin de
semaine même c'est l'été même ce soit au
début faut que tu multiplies heures de
vol après ça ce qui guide saisons que
j'ai passées cette phase là c'est bien
simple femmes est ce que c'est un bon
casting pour ce aussi parce que des fois
tu peux dire cela ce avec une belle
ligne bas mon cv ça va être prestigieux
mais tu te laisses sont aveugles ips tu
vois pas qui au fond n'est pas fait pour
ce thème c'est une femme je te fais tu
pour te dis non les affaires de même ce
que tiennent des crèmes ou j'ai dit oui
au td oui j'ai dit oui des fois puisque
enfin j'ai dit oui je pense bon
là-dedans donne un exemple 2006 rené
homier roy faisait l'émission du matin à
radio canada super émission super
animateur c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
c'est un animateur que j'apprécie je me
fais offrir aux gens de montréal de
faire une chronique hebdomadaire
c'était prestigieux c'est une belle
tribune citait pas un bon fit pour moi
j'aurais dû le savoir je le faisais pour
les mauvaises raisons il n'y était pas
un moins bon animateur et jetez pas un
moins bon chroniqueur parce que notre
chimie pensais pas si t'es pas c'était
pas mon âge deux radios et jetez pas son
genre de crime cas mais j'aurais dû le
savoir je me suis levé comme à 5 heures
du matin pendant plusieurs semaines le
jeudi pourrait les faire une chronique
avec lui qui n'apportait rien aux chocs
qui m'apportez riz mais pour le prestige
les faits ce stage stores c'est un piège
combien j'étais que j'essaie de j'essaie
de ne pas céder à ce que je n'aimerais
pas de quiz puis je vois pas faire des
missions des coûts nous
voir animer le tricheur le paquet va là
et merci infiniment
excellente question pour des gars qui
ont poids des listes de question de voir
la main ça écoute ça fait ça fait trois
ans qu'on fait ce puits je pense que
c'est en fait on fait chacun une
recherche de notre côté on s'en parle
jamais ok c'est sur le mode us open on
se parle jamais en mettant des arrivées
le fait depuis depuis 4 heures qu'on est
ici ensemble on n'a pas dit un mot sur
toi qui venaient ici ou quoi que ce soit
vous n'êtes pas dire un podium aux
joueuses et soeurs non mais c'est là bas
vous le faites très très bien bravo
et deuxièmement c'est la beauté du
format moi je toujours fasciné j'ai fait
dominique tardif qui fait un podcast qui
s'appelle deviens-tu ce que tu avais
voulu et fait le temps ça permet je
trouve de moins scripté les entrevues le
cas quand douze minutes faut façonner
hiérarchie des questions au temple voilà
ce format là c'est fascinant c'est
vraiment une conversation vous le faites
très très bien merci son acharnement je
sais que ça a été fait que sa peau est
évident qu'on connecte à non mais comme
moi je suis je prend 0 personnel les
messages qui se perdent les quais les
conflits d'horaire les gens occupés on
est juste heureux que tu as été le
finalement été une très belle experts
qui est très bonne chance merci à aa2 du
contenu excellente à tout un podcast
convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre allez
soyons patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de leur part montées sont trop
de la whey trois pièces par horace par
mois et vous avez les podcasts en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis on va recruter les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amuse tout le
temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance les entre deux toits mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que leur
chèque le podcast fini voulu nous
entendre jazz ou davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast mec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
toucher les nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille la place travot de taza taille
est là mais on jase on parle de
conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce
si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétrole il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous